ANTHONY MAYS: Welcome to
"Engineering Everyday Equity."
I'm Anthony B. Mays,
software engineer
on the data visualization
team here at Google.
In this series,
we're going to talk
about practical ways in which
we can build Equity, Diversity,
and Inclusion, or EDI, into the
product development process.
And for this episode, the
third of our three-part series,
we're going to specifically
focus on the validation
and prototyping phase.
So now I'd like to
welcome Rafael Vasquez
as we talk about the validation
phase of the design sprint
process.
Welcome, Raf.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Yeah, thanks.
You know, it's good to be here.
I'm a program manager
here at Google,
and I've seen firsthand
what can happen
when you don't take into account
getting a diverse set of users
to use your product early on.
What ends up happening is that
you end up getting tech debt.
And what you and I might
think about tech debt
is pieces of code,
or things that
don't work as they should--
ANTHONY MAYS: Right.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: --or
bugs, and we're just going
to fix it later type stuff.
ANTHONY MAYS: Right.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Right?
But tech debt is
more than just that.
Tech debt can mean things
like having your app not be
really usable for
certain communities
because of what they're in.
So as an example, I
am a program manager
that's part of the
people in sharing team,
and we worked on the photos
direct sharing feature.
But I'm also-- I was
also born in El Salvador,
and I came here, and a lot
of my family is still there.
And when we launched this, I
was really excited to show them.
Hey, this is
something I worked on.
This is so cool.
And what ended up
happening was that it
didn't work that well for them.
And what I noticed was that they
don't have the newest phones.
They don't have the best
data coverage, data plans.
And those things really hampered
how the usage of that feature
work.
And if we had started
to address those things
early on as part of our
testing and as part of our--
we could have we could
have fixed the app up.
ANTHONY MAYS: Yeah, I
can really appreciate
that, because as an
engineer, after putting
all of the hours and time
into building this application
and building what I
believe is a great product,
you end up in a
situation where you
can't get it out to people as
quickly as you may have wanted.
And so you've got
a delayed timeline,
you've got things
you've got to fix,
and those changes are probably
more expensive on the tail end
than they would have been
had we addressed them
sooner in the process, right?
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Yeah.
So actually, I was on a team
that had one of our releases
be put in jeopardy
because we did not address
screen readers early enough.
And so we had to do a
last-minute scramble
to try to get it out on time.
And if we had just
taken the time
to do that during the
prototype and validation phase
and we had made sure
that we had had someone
who would use a screen
reader as part of that group,
we wouldn't have been
in that situation.
ANTHONY MAYS: Wow, yeah.
So I can imagine that's
really frustrating.
And I also have to imagine
that those things are much more
expensive to fix later in the
process rather than sooner.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: They are.
And that's why you want to take
that time upfront to recruit
a diverse set of users when
you're prototyping and making
sure that those users actually
use all the different use
cases in your app
and in the ways
that they would normally do it.
So what's this app
that you're building?
ANTHONY MAYS: So this
app is called Scholar.
And it's about connecting
matriculating high school
students with colleges and
scholarship opportunities.
And it's really designed to
remove the frustration out
of the process of pursuing
a college education.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: So you can
take that app, and you can--
when you prototype that app,
you can take the easy route
and just see can students
find the scholarships.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK, right.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: But you want to
start looking at other things,
too.
You want to start
looking at making sure
that students of
different ethnicities
or different abilities
can find scholarships
that are geared towards them.
Because there are some
scholarships out there
that are geared towards
specific types of students.
And then if you're going to
take this app internationally,
you are also looking at other
things, too, like, let's say,
language and dialect.
There is countries
out there where
there are multiple dialects.
Can people of multiple
dialects use your app
and find information easily?
So all those things you
can take into account
when you prototype
by making sure
that you have a wide variety of
users that go through your app.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK.
And I care about all of those
different kinds of users.
All right, Raf, so how
do I find these users
from diverse backgrounds?
And when should I
start looking for them?
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Well, you should
really start looking for them
even before you start your
design sprint because you don't
want to end up in a situation
where you built a prototype,
and you need people
to use it, and you're
scrambling to find people.
That's one of the key things.
ANTHONY MAYS: Because
then it starts
to feel like more
of an afterthought.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Exactly.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK.
All right, so do I use social
media to find these users?
Or--
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Yeah, I mean,
social media is a good way.
You can figure out which
social media platforms are
popular with the users that
you want to target and post ads
there.
That's a good way of doing it.
Another way is you
could reach out
to nonprofits that are
working with the groups
that you are trying to
get feedback from and ask
for help there.
ANTHONY MAYS: That makes sense.
All right, and maybe I can go
tap some friends and family
on the shoulder, I don't know.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Well, you
should really start looking for
even before you start your
design sprint because you don't
want to end up in a situation
where you've built a prototype
and you need people
to use it and you're
scrambling to find people.
Figure out which
social media platforms
are popular with the users that
you want to target and post ads
there.
That's a good way of doing it.
Another way is you
could reach out
to nonprofits that are
working with the groups
that you're trying to get
feedback from and ask for help
that.
You also have to
remember that you
want to try to get your product
out as close to the user
as possible.
So you want to think
about remote testing,
like how do you get--
ANTHONY MAYS: Remote testing?
What's that all about?
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: You
could bring your user in,
and you could have the user
use the product in your office,
per se.
ANTHONY MAYS: Sure.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: And you'll
have a certain experience.
But that experience could
be totally different
when the user goes and uses
that product in their home,
in their daily life.
Their whole usage could
be completely different.
So you want to get as close
to the user as possible
and get their feedback
when they're using it.
ANTHONY MAYS: That's interesting
because that reminds me
of something that Bryan
Stevenson, a social justice
attorney and advocate,
once mentioned.
He talked about being
proximate to communities
that have these folks
from diverse backgrounds.
And I remember him
talking about the need
to really get close
to those communities
and meeting their
needs where they are.
And I feel like
remote testing can
be part of that process
of being proximate
with those communities.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ: Exactly.
And being proximate
with those communities
is going to just open it up to
just seeing how your app works,
and it'll save you a lot
of time in the future.
ANTHONY MAYS: All right,
so remote testing.
Yeah, that sounds
like a great idea.
I can't wait to get Scholar
in front of my users
and really meeting
them where they are.
Raf, I really appreciate
having you here.
Thanks for coming by.
RAFAEL VASQUEZ:
Thank you, thank you.
ANTHONY MAYS: And thank
you for joining us
for this episode of
"Engineering Everyday Equity."
If you'd like to learn
more, or if you'd
like to further the work
of equity, diversity,
and inclusion in your
company or product,
please visit the link in
the description below.
Also, if you have
any questions, feel
free to drop those
in the comments.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, if you do
not intentionally include,
you will
unintentionally exclude.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]